picture this it's an average Thursday
night you're just doing your thing that
thing being playing your groovy blue red
combo deck in a game of Commander with
all your cool friends you're out there
drawing the cards making the plays
living your best life the pivotal moan
fast approaches a pesky Thalia hits the
board not to fear you've got a counter
your kiky Jey meets to dissipate and
though the uing counter war is lost
you've got a backup plan you throw down
that splinter twin what follows is those
dreaded words in response it's a removal
spell suddenly this game has become a
lot less cozy what's the backup plan
champ you keep cycling through your deck
finding plenty of draw and Mana but
nothing much of use things are desperate
where do you even go from here well you
don't go from here I
mean combo holds an interesting position
within the landscape of Magic the
Gathering is it a type of deck a type of
windcom on a flavor of play
style yes it is indeed these things and
probably many more the basic gist of
what combo is is exactly what it sounds
like a combination of cards that
together do something much stronger the
spooky scary version is a two or three
card combo that wins on the spot such as
Splinter twin pestermite but there also
exist infinite mana and infinite life
combos that need additional cards to win
as well as less Game ending combos that
only win situationally or or even just
generate a lot of value though combo is
wide ranging and has undoubtedly been
part of the game for basically its whole
existence a lot of players have a
negative association with it and I think
it's useful to explore why that might
be to start with it's pretty common for
combo decks to feel uninteractive and
like they win out of nowhere you can be
doing your own game plan and watching
with Dread as your opponent spends very
little resources on board stat and
interaction instead relentlessly digging
their way toward a one- turn win until
either they find it or you reduce their
life to to zero this kind of magic isn't
particularly fun for anybody it's just
another kind of
solitire the other thing I've seen
complaints about is the fact that in a
way a lot of combo decks break the rules
of the game as understood by most
players games that involve conventional
aggro mid-range and control decks
feature a Common Language board presence
is a thing to be fought over and cards
in life total exist as resources to be
taken into consideration and leveraged
by contrast combo deex throw this
playbook in the toilet they operate
using additional more subtle resources
and they can win even when they are
behind in board State life total and
hand
size now there are a lot of things to be
said about these points but I'll keep it
to this for now the volatility and
uninteractive of combo de can indeed be
negatives and I will be talking about
how to minimize them however breaking
the conventional rules of the game can
be a good thing particularly in a format
like EDH the fact that Commander is a
format with 40 Health per player and
three opponents rather than one
encourages some styles of play which are
too risky in 20 Health 1v1 formats these
empowered Styles tend to be slower and
greedier than a lot of what you find in
other formats in midow EDH it's very
common to see Decks that pile on heaps
upon heaps of creature-based value and
then you get decks like my gissa list
calling card mid-range Crusher 5000 that
make it their whole goal to demolish
these sorts of decks by piling on an
even larger amount of greed and though I
enjoy playing mid-range Crusher 5000 I
know that this environment isn't always
a very Dynamic one a game where everyone
always has big piles of value generating
permanence and where turns involved five
minutes of abilities and triggers with
little movement or strategy or actual
action isn't one I enjoy finding myself
in the fact that there are Decks that
can cut through the slow greedy board
Center decks is a good
thing now that I've laid out why I think
Combos and combo decks occupy a useful
Niche we can ask the question of the
video where do they usually go wrong in
EDH I think a lot of it comes down to
the structure of the decks the example I
gave in the intro is a deck that's
basically an EDH adaptation of 2015 era
modern Splinter twin a pure combo deck
and the operative word for why that
doesn't work so well is pure so okay
there's this weird paradoxical thing as
you get to higher and higher powers in
Commander combo becomes more and more
ubiquitous for the simple fact that
everybody's got 120 Health to Chisel
through right and it takes a lot of time
to Fair magic your way through that
level of meat but what this also means
is that Stacks cards to slow down and
break combos also become ubiquitous much
more ubiquitous than they are in a 20
Health 1v1 format the result is that
pure combo actually works better in
conventional formats and it is indeed
very common for combo deck in these
formats to have no other wincons by
contrast for a high power commander
player who must always contend with the
possibility of encountering a quagmire
of stacks effects and counter spells
it's a good idea to run alternate
wincons just to be safe as a highle
example we can consider Dargo thos a
partner Commander pair that is sometimes
played in competitive EDH thos is a
beast of a card it's a generally decent
value engine and more importantly it's
an outlet for infinite Mana combos
that's in the command Zone you combo off
to get your infinite mana and then you
play thasos and draw through your deck
to find the kill good stuff thasos is
real good Dargo is there to add a bunch
of utility he can be used with life's
Legacy or greater good to generate cards
and he can also be sacked to Neo former
pod to grab tidde spouts for one of the
decks combos he also more pertinently to
the point here is a beefy boy who can
threap your opponents and that can be a
useful thing to have in your pocket if
your combo plan gets shut down somewhere
along the road the multiple different
combo wions along along with the backup
Beatdown wicon make the deck exceedingly
flexible and adaptable and help it to
weather a lot of challenging
situations however I hear a clamoring
but Alex I hear some of you say I'm not
a cedh player I'm not going to be facing
a wall of stacks high enough to be an
eighth wonder of the world and you know
what that's fair so for now let's stop
considering what's good and switch to
considering what's fun and what works
well within a somewhat lower powered
group for starters I'm going to have to
crush your dreams a little combos are
powerful and can be quite fun but it's
important that the combos be well
situated within a deck this means that
if a combo is Central to the deck the
deck should be able to pull it off
reasonably consistently with the
Assumption of at least light resistance
from your opponents if the combo is less
Central to the deck it should blend in
naturalistically with the deck requiring
mostly cards and types of setup the deck
achieves through its normal game plan
and not feeling wildly out of sync with
the normal game plan if you put a
two-card infinite combo in your low
power mid-range deck your deck is going
to be a low power mid-range deck 90% of
the time and an unprotected infinite
combo deck 10% of the time that's going
to give your play group some serious
Whiplash and it's decidedly not an
example of fun and dynamic gameplay see
part two of my budget cards video if you
want to hear me waffle about this topic
for another 5 minutes or
so for an example of an elegant
execution of a lower power combo deck
I'm going to use a deck for my friend Mr
Hans because he's much more of a Johnny
than I'll ever be
he built a vodro deck it's a toolbox
mutate deck that tries to generate value
through its commander and a suite of
other value engines throughout the deck
an equipment sub theme with several
tutors also exists within the deck
giving it access to several reconfigure
cards which offer various forms of
utility as well as the central pillar of
the deck
sunforger with sunforger the deck has
accessed yet a further Suite of options
assorted interaction draw spells and
burst damage and also a couple of
distinctly spicier
cards glorious end can put an immediate
stop to a problematic combat phase or
effectively counter a concerning spell
and chance for Glory is an extra turn
spell that also doubles as a protection
spell for both cards Angel's Grace can
be played on the following turn in order
to prevent the lose the game
Clause this is a decidedly useful tool
on its own but it is also within the
interaction between these cards and the
mutate mechanic that the combo exists
vadra can repeat lowcost n creature
spells from the graveyard when creatures
mutate onto it and since the mutate
stack counts as a single creature a
bounce spell Returns the entire stack to
hand so the combo goes something like
this get an extra turn via chance for
Glory and prevent loss on that turn via
Angel's Grace then repeat this on each
subsequent extra turn by mutating three
creatures onto vodro one for chance one
for grace and one for a bounce spell if
you have the correct setup this means
infinite turns and infinite combat steps
Swinging with body qu
Rock something you may note about this
is that as combos go this one is very
convoluted and difficult to achieve in
addition to the three cards required for
the combo there is also the requirement
of having 14 mana and three mutate
creatures as well as the
commander however this is actually okay
for a couple of different reasons for
one fodra isn't a pure combo deck
maintaining a solid mutate stack with
the commander leads to having a decent
beater that deals Commander damage and
generates a lot of value the deck isn't
playing at high power levels and it can
and does win games simply by hitting
people drawing cards and holding up
enough protection to prevent the stack
from dying a common strategy for the
deck is to build the stack on top of a
man land which allows it to dodge
sorcery speed removal in general and
board wipes in particular and the
pivotal sunforger boosts vod's power to
seven the exact amount you need to kill
a player in three hits it's a very real
wind plan with a solid shell for
generating value and controlling things
the other reason the difficulty of
setting up the combo is okay is that all
three of the combo pieces have their own
utility and more importantly the
requirement of having a lot of mutate
creatures in Mana is achieved by the
deck just generally doing what it wants
to be doing generating a lot of value
leads to drawing into mutate creatures
and Mana rocks and successfully
protecting its ever important sunforger
allows the deck to grab its combo pieces
everything needed to set up the combo is
a solid goal in its own right so simply
playing the deck in ways that are
generally effective also
naturalistically leads into having the
combo sometimes the combo will get
stopped but if it does guess what the
deck has been doing a good job of
pursuing its General goals so you're
still going to have a decent shot of
winning via Commander
damage this idea of combo fitting
naturally into the deck is the biggest
thing I want to convey here a combo you
run shouldn't feel abrupt or out of
place it shouldn't feel like the deck
does not nothing or everything depending
on if it draws a certain three or four
cards if you've got a deck with a combo
is the centerpiece you should run Tutors
or big piles of draw in order to get
there with control cards used as a sort
of extending element to buy the deck
time if you have a deck where it's going
to take a long time to put together the
combo you should fill up space in the
deck with a game plan that works
concurrently with that setup process uh
that can be ramping in a deck where the
combo is Mana intensive or running lots
of draw in a deck where the com involves
looping with a number of different cards
or running tutors in a deck where
getting toet pieces together is a
challenge and then once you've
constructed a framework for piling on
particular resources you can devise how
to fit in an alternative win plan that
also takes advantage of those
resources don't trust your combo to win
you the game because guess what removal
counters and stacks exist and optimizing
your combo deck is going to put you at
power levels where increas in quantities
of these Road Blocks
exist as a final point I want to discuss
the opposite of a combo Deck with an
alternative Beatdown wicon that being a
Beatdown Deck with an alternative combo
wicon now this is a little more unusual
but hear me out here sometimes a
Beatdown deck is able to get ahead on
resources but then it gets locked out of
swinging for onboard damage for some
reason or other for example a couple
years back I built a $25 grismold The
Dread sour deck a fast mid range deck
plan a of the deck is the pseudo Voltron
Beatdown plan where the deck creates a
bunch of tokens on board and then
deletes said tokens in order to swing in
for lethal amounts of Commander damage
you might note however that the deck is
not running blue and a $25 budget is too
small to afford nice shoes for my
grismold and as you might expect there
are games where grismold kind of just
gets bullied out of existence by removal
so what else can you do with a lot of
tokens dying run some blood IR to of
course the win plan of generate tokens
place your Conrad and then kill the
tokens isn't as effective at killing
players as a pure Voltron Griz mold plan
but relying on the Grizzy plan alone is
a bad idea and having a backup means
that the deck can win even if it just
gets a couple medium-sized GIS mold
swings rather than living the dream and
one tapping three players back to back
the important Point here is that both of
these Windon use the same basic resource
tokens so the deck doesn't really need
to do anything different to have both of
these windc cons and this is the Crux of
things really at lower Powers alternate
windc cons should ideally be using the
same resources as the main wind conon
for the sake of deck cohesion and when
in doubt just engineer your deck so that
it has a mey lad it can use just in case